Apple scans your phone for illegal content,
Master faces are able to bypass almost any
facial recognition software, and WALL-E is
real.
Welcome to ml news, it's Monday.
All right before we get into things, this
video is sponsored by weights and biases,
weights and biases is of course, the one stop
shop for any machine learning researcher or
practitioners, weights and biases can track
your experiments with a single line of code.
It lets you reproduce and analyze your experiments.
It lets you understand your data.
It's with you all the way from conception,
idea, research, development, up until deployment.
Today I want to talk to you about a feature
called sweeps.
Now, a sweep in weights and biases is a hyper
parameter optimization search, if you will.
The cool thing is you define your experiment,
you define the range of parameters you want
to search over, and then the system does the
rest for you.
You can even run this in a distributed fashion,
you can have lots of agents at lots of different
places, they are going to pull the code from
the central server, pull the new hyper parameters,
try them out and then report back.
In the background, there is a Bayesian optimization
algorithm going on deciding what parameters
to try next to optimize your objective, they
even have early stopping, so you don't waste
resources on runs that are clearly going nowhere,
and have I mentioned, you can run this in
a distributed fashion.
So here's one of my sweeps, as you can see,
you get your output as you're used to from
weights and biases.
In a neat dashboard, you get an overview over
all your runs.
But in addition, you're able to see the progress
of the sweep, you're able to see which ones
succeeded and which ones didn't, it will analyze
directly how important each one of the parameters
is individually.
So here it tells me that the learning rate
is the most important parameter, and it has
a positive correlation with my objective function.
One of the coolest views is this one here
that tells me which of the combinations of
hyper parameter ended up at a certain place.
So I can filter for runs with particularly
low validation loss.
And then I can see what are the learning rates,
what are the epochs like in this particular
runs.
Now there's obviously much more you can do
in terms of analyzing sweeps, you can run
this much larger, you can look at individual
samples of your best runs pretty much everything
you're used to from weights and biases.
So if until now you've tuned your hyper parameters
manually try this out, let it do the work
for you go to bed and in the morning, come
back to find the system has found the best
possible hyper parameters for your problem.
Not only is it easier, but you'll understand
more about your problem once you see it in
this light.
Of course, this is only one of the features
of weights and biases.
They have many, many more, including ways
to analyze your data ways to export your models,
ways to keep track of everything that you're
doing, and ways to send reports around to
other people, or generally work in teams.
Personal accounts are free with unlimited
experiments for you.
If you're an enterprise that will cost a bit
of money, but hey, you're an enterprise.
And there are free options for academic teams.
There are even options to self host if you
need to be compliant with any sort of regulation.
So give it a try, go over to weights and biases.
That's wandb I think at least that's how you
pronounce it.
wandb.ai and fun, ciao!
All right, our first story today is not a
particularly fun story.
TechCrunch writes, Apple confirms it will
begin scanning iCloud photos for child abuse
images.
This has caused quite a bit of stir in the
community, especially since Apple had all
these adverts in the previous series about
what happens on your phones stays on your
phone was very privacy related end to end
encryption friendly and all of these kinds
of stuff.
And now all of a sudden, it seems like they're
going to scan all your data for things they
don't like.
Of course, it's not a case in favor of child
abuse images or any kind of illegal content.
People are worried about privacy more generally.
So I think it's important to say what exactly
is going to happen here or at least from what
we know, Apple will scan your photos that
you were about to upload to iCloud.
As I understand it, iCloud itself is encrypted.
So Apple technically has no way to scan the
iCloud photos because they are encrypted with
your key that rests on your devices.
However, they can scan content that's on your
phone, I'm gonna guess there might be a legal
reason for it in that they might sort of kind
of be responsible for that content once it
goes to their online service.
However, that's not something I know.
But of course once the technical methodology
is in place to scan the photos that are about
to be uploaded to iCloud from your device,
you can use this same technology to essentially
get access to any data of any user.
There's no technical limitation, after all,
why only these photos should be scan.
And just because Apple promises that it won't
do it doesn't mean they won't do it in the
future, or they can't do it.
And that already tells you a little bit why
some people say it is a problem, because of
course, there is also no technical limitation
that says that it can only scan for child
abuse images or any sort of illegal content.
And for that, it's a little bit important
to dig into what the system actually does.
So the way this works is, there's no classifier
essentially in there to classify child abuse
images from non child abuse images, there
is a database.
So the police essentially collect databases
of these materials, which means that those
are individual photographs or movies that
are sent around by certain people that are
illegal, and the police keeps track exactly
of the files that go around.
So this is the first important thing, they
only want to detect if you on your phone have
one of the files that they already have in
their database classified as illegal content,
and the way they do it is by comparing hashes.
Now, traditionally, a hash would only match
if the file is exactly the same bit for a
bit.
So what you do as your phone would download
the database of hashes would hash all the
photos on your device that are about to be
uploaded to iCloud, wink, and then it would
compare those hashes to the database of bad
hashes.
And if one matches, it would upload it to
the police.
Alternatively, it could just hash all the
contents, upload that to the police.
And then the police could do the comparison
in any way.
If these are actually true hashes, they're
unlikely to reveal what data you have on your
phone.
And that's likely the argument that Apple
is going to make right here.
And that just because you upload the hashes
of what's on your phone, you can't necessarily
reconstruct the images from that.
So your personal photos are safe, even more
so if your phone downloads all of these hashes,
and then compares them locally and only sends
if in fact, there is a match.
However, there are multiple problems with
this.
First of all, you don't know what's going
in this database, technically, some political
party could simply enter things into that
database that they know are likely the opposition
or some rebel group is likely to share around
amongst themselves, they could even instigate
such material, and then they could just wait
and see what phones blip up.
So you confiscate one phone from your political
opponent, you run all these hashes, and you
put them in the database, and all the phones
of the associates of that person would then
be automatically reported by the system.
So the potential for abuse here of the people
who control what's in the database is enormous.
Second, as I understand it, the hashes that
are used right here aren't like classic cryptographic
hashes.
They are what Apple calls neural hash, but
what is in effect, a locality sensitive hashing
algorithm.
So here's an article by Tyler neilan, about
locality sensitive hashing, which explains
the concept fairly well.
And it makes sense to use a locality sensitive
hash in this case, because what you want to
detect is if two images are the same meaning
display the same thing.
For example, if I take an image and then run
some sort of JPEG compression on it, it still
shows me the same thing.
However, the bits have all changed.
So a classic hash would not be able to recognize
that image anymore.
However, a Content Aware hash would or should
at least be able to recognize that this is
the same image YouTube has been doing this
for a long time with their content ID system,
detecting when someone re uploads a video
by someone else, even if that video has been
re encoded.
So as far as I understand it, what Apple does
is they train some kind of neural network
that gives them a representation of what is
in an image.
And then they run that through a locality
sensitive hashing procedure.
locality sensitive hashing is essentially
a system that allows you to find neighbors
in very high dimensional space very efficiently.
So the neural network would produce a space
of images and place each image somewhere with
the intention that images containing similar
or the same thing would fall very close to
each other.
And you can do that with neural network.
The question is, you don't want to run an
inner product search over this whole space
all the time, like that would fry your phone,
probably.
So what locality sensitive hashing does, essentially,
it divides up this space into buckets.
So here, it's straight buckets.
And then these kinds of buckets.
Once you combine all these buckets, you get
the sub bucket, so you get sort of a division
of space and for each point you can check
is it to the left or to the right of a particular
line.
And if two points match in being to the left
or to the right, or up or down respectively,
towards Any particular line, that means they're
in the same bucket and probably very close
together at that point, then you can actually
go ahead and check if they are actually close
together or not.
This is a good way to find approximately nearest
neighbors in high dimensions.
So real LSH algorithms are a bit more sophisticated.
But that's the essential concept they work
by.
So is this going to help?
Well, I would say yes, in first instance.
But then I think very, very quickly, you'll
realize that adversarial attacks, for example,
can be crafted against these kinds of systems.
Given that the system computes the hash on
your phone, that means you have access to
the model on your phone and having access
to a model as a very, very, very good target
for crafting adversarial attacks.
Technically, there could now be a an entire
market of systems that are turb images on
your phone automatically, such that they just
scramble the LSH because most of these hashes
aren't going to be in the database.
So if I just assigned my image, some random
hash, meaning I run an adversarial attack
such that it is just going to be somewhere
in this space, most likely, I won't hit any
of the hashes in the database, and therefore,
all my photos are not going to cause any hash
collisions, and therefore, I completely evade
that system.
Now the question is, of course, how easy is
this going to be?
Especially given that it is posed to circumvent
detection of illegal content, there's going
to be a bit of resistance.
But there's definitely quite easy ways it
seems to circumvent this system.
And we have to ask ourselves, are we really
ready to give up basic privacy?
Are we really ready to let the companies build
in these giant backdoors that have massive
potential for abuse for what is essentially
a method that can be pretty easily evaded?
when it's used for what it's really supposed
to be used for.
I don't have the answers, but I would err
on the side of user privacy.
So that's my take on it.
Tell me what you think in the comments.
All right, a quick afterthought.
Here, we now also have the technical summary
of Apple, there's a lot of content in here.
Notably, it goes into a lot of detail on how
exactly the technology works, what neural
hash is supposed to do, for example, you can
see that the left and middle image have the
same neural hash, whereas the right image
does not have the same neural hash.
So the neural hash is supposed to be robust
to certain transformations that you might
do with the image while still preserving its
content.
Therefore, as I said, you couldn't just compress
the image or change its color saturation a
little bit and evade the neural hash.
Apparently, though, after the neural hash
is computed, there is also this blinding step,
which means that it essentially goes through
a classic hash function, and therefore the
adversarial attacks on the system become a
little bit more difficult.
Now, since this is all still on device, it's
absolutely possible to evade the neural hash
using an adversarial attack.
What is less possible is to frame someone
meaning that you send someone an image that
is specifically crafted who hit the neural
hash filters as illegal content, but it's
actually just kind of a normal image that
you have adversarially crafted now with an
untargeted adversarial attack, you can evade
the filter.
But if you want to trip the filter, you really
need a targeted adversarial attack.
And because of this blinding step, you don't
know what to target.
So the only way to actually craft such an
adversarial image to frame someone is if you
yourself, already have an illegal image that
you can target with the adversarial attacks.
So there's a lot more in this technical report
right here.
And I invite you to read it if you are interested.
And I might actually do a full video on this.
If this is interesting enough to people, not
necessarily machine learning.
It's more cryptography and systems design.
But still, it's pretty cool.
All right.
While we're on privacy, the EU parliament
approves mass surveillance of private communications
from the European Pirate Party writing today
the European Parliament approved the E privacy
derogation, allowing providers of email and
messaging services to automatically search
all personal messages of each citizen for
presumed suspect content and report suspected
cases to the police.
European pirates delegation in the green CFA
group strongly condemns this automated mass
surveillance which effectively means the end
privacy in digital correspondence.
So this sounds kind of the same, but it is
slightly different.
While Apple announced that it will do something
this is simply the EU saying that you can
do something however what you can do now seems
to be a pretty big breach of privacy.
Now of course, just because companies now
are allowed to do something doesn't mean they
will do it, but probably it means they will
do it.
So, yeah, but what are you gonna do you signal
well, then just Apple swoops in and scans
your messages before you send them.
So I guess we'll just go back to sending pigeons
around.
Alright, on a bit of a lighter note, I stumbled
across this book by a RenChu Wang that explains
machine learning as answering two basic questions.
So this company's a machine learning class
and explains machine learning in the essentially
answering FAQ's.
This is a big FAQ of that class, and it's
quite good.
It's explained very concisely.
What do embedding layers do?
embedding layers converted token, an integer
to a vector, a list of floating point numbers?
Oh, that's fairly concise.
And then you say when do you use embedding
layers?
When you want to process text, text can be
converted to integers?
Because neural networks are don't directly
understand integers.
They'd have a typo here, I guess, could I
change this, I can make a pull request.
Suggest edit for check.
Cool.
I was pretty stupid.
And actually, the recording you're seeing
is the second recording.
In fact, I forgot the first time to record
my screen.
And what happened is pretty funny in that
so I was I was presenting this book.
And I actually saw a typo in the book.
And then I immediately opened a pull request
and fix the typo.
And the pull request got approved.
And I was like, Yay, ML news and all and I
thought that would make for some pretty good
content.
And I was really happy with myself.
And it was really neat and all and then I
realized I forgot to record the screen.
So now I'm just going to show you a compilation
of me being absolutely self congratulatory
for finding a typo.
Have fun.
Good job, ML news community, we did something.
Give yourselves a pat on the shoulder is this
is this is unplanned?
Yeah, ml news improving the world story by
story.
So as you can see, it is not entirely thorough
or particularly technically accurate or anything
like this.
If you're a beginner, if you're new into a
particular subfield of machine learning that's
treated here, this might be a good place seems
fairly concise way to learn about the fundamentals
of given subfields.
Okay, we have some new data sets coming out
two data sets by Google both are for NLP is
specially for conversation, what is called
time dial and it tests the model's understanding
of sort of the sequence of things whether
or not eight understands the flow of time.
And especially if the participants in the
conversation talk about things that happened
one after another if the model can correctly
infer things about this.
So here we can see, What's the date today.
Today is September 28 2007.
I have a meeting this afternoon.
When will it begin?
I'll begin at three o'clock, What's the time
now and then the model is asked to fill in
this blank, It is something something and
then continues to go nowm I don't want to
be late.
The model says Don't worry, time is enough.
What's the most likely filling in the blank?
So you'd have to reason the K meeting is this
afternoon, it will begin at three yet after
that it says okay, I have to go now, but time
is enough.
So maybe it's a bit before three, you know,
not like 123 or something like this, but also
not the day before or so.
So out of the four options you have here,
the first ones would be okay, because they
fit the constraints.
The last ones would not be okay.
And in fact in this absolutely not cherry
picked example, I'm sure the T fi both t five
and bird design, most mass to the last examples.
The data set is essentially made up of all
kinds of these conversations and giving you
options to fill in and you have to determine
the ones that fit the constraints most the
other data set is called dis full QA and tests
disappoint questions.
So it takes the squad data set, which is a
question answering data set and it rewrites
it into questions where the speaker just kind
of turns around made question or corrects
themselves or insert something or says like,
Oh, no, that's not what I meant done.
And this other thing, and this can get quite
complicated because you can start with an
entity and then say, Oh, no, no, no, no, no,
but then still refer to that entity when you
rephrase your question.
So the data set is supposed to test the model's
abilities to handle that.
Data sets like this in general are pretty
cool because they test sort of human aspects
of conversation, however state of the art
On these datasets is probably going to be
reached by models that just heavily overfit
to whatever their problems that data set construction
mechanism is.
So if you evaluate things on these data sets,
what I think should be done is you should
just train like your regular model without
these things in mind, and then evaluate on
them as sort of one of the things maybe we
can add those to to the superglue suite or
something like this, would you give us a more
accurate picture than simply releasing them
and then have a leaderboard for them, that's
just my opinion.
In other data set news.
Facebook research releases Vox Populi, which
is a speech data set.
So their speech data from the European Parliament
event recordings, some of them are even annotated
or translated, interpreted into other languages.
So this is a very big data set unlabeled and
labeled speech data.
So if you work with speech, this might be
something interesting for you.
Next news, Google tensor debuts on the new
pixel six this fall.
Google tensor apparently is some sort of hardware,
I don't know, this is a giant marketing piece,
it just says the Google tensor chip will make
everything very, very fast and machine learning
and the new UI.
And they don't their sense of the editor will
actually say anything about the chips.
So your phone is going to be able to do number
three, number three, crunchy, crunchy way
faster than it used to be able to do it.
That's all I can say for now.
The Pentagon believes its pre cognitive AI
can predict events days in advance machine
learning could help the military make proactive
decisions writes, engadget.
So this is an article and it sounds a bit
like out of a dystopian movie.
But apparently, the US military has very large
efforts into using ml to sort of predict icky
situations that are about to happen.
And once you read into it, it's apparently
not that different from what they've done
so far.
So far, they just had like a whole bunch of
people analyze all kinds of satellite imagery,
or emails from people that they just found
on their computer, like people sent it to
them, their private emails.
That's why they can read them legally.
And they just had all these people go through
all this data, essentially, manually, maybe
with some assistance.
And now AI is supposed to just be able to
go through this data a lot quicker and flag
any information that might be relevant for
the human reviewers, the technology itself
seems fairly neutral and actually pretty useful
in certain situations.
Given that it's the military using it, it
might have a bit of a bad rep.
But again, it demonstrates that most technology
doesn't really have a sort of moral underpinning
by itself.
It's mostly in most cases about the deployment
of any type of technology, like you could
use the same thing to predict days or minutes
or hours in advance when ICU patients will
become unstable if people actually do it.
And the underlying core technology is not
going to look very different from what is
done here.
So researchers from MIT and CMU release sketch
your own, again, which is a paper and the
method in the paper is essentially you take
a gan that you have trained on some sort of
data set D. Here, for example, on a cat data
set, and you're able to additionally input
a sketch, as you can see right here, and the
system will adapt the GANs looks at the outputs
served of match that sketch course, there's
quite a number of hyper parameters in here,
a lot of engineering decisions.
But in essence, it's a pretty, pretty cool
way to control the output of GANs.
And this is quite a hard thing to do.
And it's not entirely clear how to do it,
a lot of people research sort of disentanglement
of features in GANs, so you can control individual
dimensions directly.
But that kind of requires you to have either
a data set of these individual dimensions,
so you can actually really take them apart
or you just end up with some dimensions, and
you have to figure out what they are in order
to control it seems like a pretty cool thing.
You can give the GANs a sample and in this
case, not even a sample of real data, you
can actually give the GANs sort of a steering
direction directly of what you want it to
output.
So I can see this has many more applications
beyond images and sketches.
Technically, you could apply this to a lot
more stuff where you need to control the output
of a generative model by some sort of demonstration
which doesn't even necessarily have to be
in the same space as the things you're trying
to produce.
So overall, very cool.
Check it out.
Next paper that caught my attention can a
fruit fly learn word embeddings by a whole
consortium of researchers of different labs
working together on this paper now.
It's clickbait.
Let me explain, the paper itself is actually
pretty cool.
So we understand fruit fly brains fairly well,
they're approximately like this.
Now when I read the title of this paper is
I want to see a fruit fly, learn word embeddings,
or at least an attempt at doing these kinds
of things.
However, it turns out that the paper construct
a sort of abstract model of the fruit fly
brain and then shows that that abstract model
can in fact, learn word embeddings, much like
the word embedding methods that we know from
NLP, again, the research itself is completely
valid and very cool.
I was just sort of caught out by how important
a title of a paper is, because had it been
for a different title, technical title, I
probably would not have clicked on it.
So the lesson is, if you're trying to get
people to read your paper, a good title can
go a long way.
Okay, the last paper that caught my eye is
generating master faces for dictionary attacks
with a network system latent space evolution.
This by the Blavatnik School of computer science
in Tel Aviv, and by the School of Electrical
Engineering in Tel Aviv.
This paper essentially uses evolutionary algorithms.
And I love the Darwin in this picture.
Just to make clear, we mean Darwinian evolution
and not lamarckian evolution, hashtag no Lamarck.
So this paper constructs what they call master
faces, and apparently just these faces just
10 faces.
So each of these rows, or these master faces,
just these faces combined are able to match
a vast number of facial detection algorithms.
So what that means is, if I go out and I encounter
a facial recognition system to like, let me
into a door or into a phone or anything like
this, I can just try out these 10 faces and
there is a high likelihood something like
40 to 50% at one of them will actually work,
which is insane.
This shows sort of the brittleness of the
identification part of these facial recognition
algorithms.
The potential for abuse for this is large,
like someone could get access to all the photos
that you're about to upload to iCloud or something
like this, like imagine that that'd be terrible.
Fix this!
Alright we just have one helper library this
week, Pytorch releases the pytorch profiler
version 1.9.
So this seems to be a rather major upgrade.
That includes distributed training view, memory
view, GPU utilization, view cloud storage
support, and jump to source code, which replaces
the old feature of walk to source code.
Well, in any case, if you use pytorch, and
you ask yourself why your code is so slow,
maybe try giving the pytorch profiler a look.
Next news.
0AD is getting reinforcement learning capabilities.
This is a strategy game that is kind of popular
with some people.
The cool thing is that it has now a direct
interface for reinforcement learning, meaning
that it exposes an API that is essentially
compatible with the gym interface that you
know from basic RL.
So they even go through setting up some sort
of a task for you with these five spearmen
fighting against these five cavalry.
And they take you through training a dq n
agent and then evaluating it directly in their
game.
So if you're interested in reinforcement learning
as it pertains to controlling games, maybe
this is a good topic for you to dive in.
And the last news, Yahoo News writes, beach,
bot rover uses artificial intelligence to
clean up cigarette butts.
So apparently, there once was an engineer
whose son dug up a cigarette butt at the beach.
And the engineer looked around and saw all
kinds of cigarette butts lying around, realized
that they're quite bad for the environment,
and also not very pleasant to step into.
So he teamed up with this friend and build
this thing called beach bot or BB for short.
So this is essentially an incarnation of Wally,
it goes around and automatically picks up
cigarette butts at the beach.
How cute is that?
How neat.
So it does that fully automatically.
I think the bigger goal here is to sort of
develop AI and robotics applications for sustainability.
The project in itself is not going to save
the world.
Here they writes.
It can scoop up about 10 cigarette butts with
its grippers within 30 minutes, and it has
to recharge about once every hour.
So pretty much it's out competed hopelessly
by a single chain smoker.
But what can I say it's very, very cool, but
I think that your robot could be better use
to actually go and just poke people who smoke
at the beach in the first place.
So BB will get a companion pokey.
BB and pokey best friends on the beach.
Let's go Stab some smokers and then pick up
a cigarette butt.
All right, that was already it for this week's
ML news on this beautiful, beautiful Monday.
I hope you learned something today if you
did subscribe, if you did not, watch the video
again then subscribe.
Please check out weights and biases and I
wish you a very pleasant week.
I'll see you around.
Bye bye